bonjour et aymeric lycée merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous dans la
matinale d'air france alors on a vu
la mise à l'arrêt en tout cas des
tractations diplomatiques après
l'annnonce de la reconnaissance par
vladimir poutine des républiques
populaires du donbass
le processus de minsk n'existe plus
comme en face pour ce qu'est ce que les
tractations diplomatiques vont elles
pouvoir se poursuivre dans ces
conditions selon vous
alors c'est l'intérêt des différentes
parties qu'est ce qu'elles se
poursuivent parce qu'en réalité ni la
russie l'ukraine les pays européens les
états unis ne veulent une guerre en
ukraine les conséquences seraient
beaucoup trop importante et il ya il
file et une volonté des différents
acteurs de trouver des accords et donc
de ce point de vue là c'était plutôt une
bonne idée la part d'un et mâcon
d'essayer de maintenir le fil
diplomatique il a échoué avec finalement
une augmenté élisant tension et un
accroissement des tensions en ukraine et
à long terme la seule issue possible ne
peut-être que la voie diplomatique
parce qu'il faudra ce défilé se remettre
autour de la table il faudra choisir et
renégocier on trouvait un nouveau de
nouveaux accords puisque les accords de
l'isc fait depuis 2014 ont été violés a
de nombreuses fois par les différentes
parties à quelle nécessité de se
remettre autour de la table ces accords
de minsk dont vous parlez il date de
2014 il ya eu minsk 1-1 et puis minsk 2
peu sous l'égide de l'allemagne et de la
france ça fait huit ans que emmanuel
macron aussi a tenu d des sommets en
format normandie en france l'ukraine a
refusé de signer de signer ces accords
finalement est-ce que c'est pas non plus
une responsabilité franco-allemande de
ne pas avoir suffisamment appuyée pour
que ces accords soient signés aussi que
deux côté ukrainien
la station de l'ukraine est un peu
particulière c'est finalement le pays
est coupé en deux entre une partie est
ce qui est plutôt pro-russe est il parti
ou est-ce pour européen elle qui voit la
russie plutôt comme en danger qui
souhaite accélérer ses processus
d'adhésion à l'otan ou à l'union
européenne à tout ce qui pourrait la
protéger d'une forme de séparatisme et
et de la russie cette situation là vient
de fait accroître les tensions la
perception du côté russe d'un danger
pour la russie l'intégration du crel
dans dans l'otan et et tout ce qui
pourrait il se pourrait s'ensuivre la
question de l'allemagne est intéressante
c'est que l'allemagne est à la fois
diplomatiquement essentiellement alignée
sur la position américaine sur
l'ensemble des sujets et en même temps
est l'un des partenaires majeurs
notamment avec dans scream 2 il serait
question énergétique et industrielle
avec la russie et donc on a senti durant
cette crise la position un peu difficile
de l'allemagne tant d'un point de vue
diplomatique conomique pris entre des
intérêts parfois contraire et donc c'est
un point majeur ce qu'on peut constater
finalement c'est l'allemagne fait le
choix et le parti d'un résident coûté
dix occidentaux a suspendu leur scream 2
qui en fait est un moyen de redonner un
levier d'action à l'ukraine en empêchant
le gaz russe d'être exportées par ne
sais pas mais flamand à l'ukraine de
récupérer son levier d'action de bloquer
ou pas l'importation de gaz russe vers
l'europe puisque actuellement le seul
gazoduc qui fonctionne passe par
l'ukraine donc c'est redonner la main
finalement un petit peu à l'ukraine pour
lever les volontés de la dernière
poutine de te mettre de la pression sur
l'ukraine alors sur le plan politique en
france précisément emmanuel macron a
voulu assurer cette présidence de
l'union européenne
il a pris un risque emmanuel macron il a
voulu se poser en médiateur justement
dans cette crise avec des résultats
finalement qui ont été vains est-ce
qu'il a pris un risque et est ce que ça
peut influer en tout cas sur sa sa
popularité auprès des français
tout à fait il a pris il a pris son
risque politique emmanuel macron il a
une crise internationale quelques mois
des élections présidentielles s'ils
réussissaient à obtenir une désescalade
l'accord diplomatique qui pouvaient
s'inscrire dans la grande lignée des
grands dirigeants européens comme
françois mitterrand avec le chancelier
kohl face à la menace de l'urss et
porter la voix de la france à celle de
toute évidence il a échoué puisque il
n'y a pas eu deux d'avancé
matériel qu'à chaque fois que l'elysée
afin communiqué le kremlin a démenti les
avancées et les propos et les propos de
l'elysée il c'est un échec est ce que
pour autant politiquement d'un point de
vue électoral vival payer c'est moins
sûr puisque en fait à un présupposé
c'est que finalement est-ce que les
autres candidates sont prises en ciel
aurait fait mieux pour l'instant les
français de la perception que non mais
si on compare aux prédécesseurs
d'emmanuel bacon françois hollande et
nicolas sarkozy là la question plus
ambigu françois hollande avait réussi à
porter la première foncière peser dans
les derniers instants des négociations
des accords de bisque et nicolas sarkozy
avait réussi à embarquer toute l'europe
lors de sa présidence française de
l'union européenne notamment pour sauver
l'europe durant la crise financière est
aussi d'un point de vue de la russie
avec la question la chirurgie en
obtenant finalement des îles filets des
accords qui était plutôt à l'avantagé
européen et avoir une stabilisation de
la région donc par rapport à ses
prédécesseurs mais alors qu'on fait
moins bien par rapport aux autres
candidats élection présidentielle
électoralement il devrait pas le payer
puisque il ne voit pas d'autres
candidats et les rejette capable de
faire mieux mais cet avantage
durablement son image est ce que c'est
une question finalement ces questions de
politique étrangère qui iront de l'
influence sur le choix des électeurs
alors c'est ça des influences notamment
en cas des malades mâcon qui a fait le
choix d'entamer comme ces questions
européennes est un seul comme un
marqueur de démarcation par rapport à
ses concurrents
des trous dessus de la mêlée et
d'incarner la voix de la france dans le
monde et de doutes d'appuyer sa
supériorité sur une forme de présentiel
présente dix sites présentent d'ici
habilité supérieur et d'être sur des
thématiques plus tôt de haut niveau
alors que la campagne est plutôt
médiocre sur des thématiques du
quotidien est en décalage avec les
attentes des français donc c'était un
avantage est ce que les français se
positionneront autant uniquement par
rapport à ces questions là évidemment
non viable si les questions de pouvoir
d'achat les questions de sécurité mais
ces questions là à l'échelle
internationale les français sont très
préoccupés et s'intéresse à ce qui se
passe dans le monde notamment leurs
frontières européennes donc ça aura de
l'impact un sujet qui va devenir majeur
dans cette campagne la gestion de cette
crise le rôle de la france
internationale comment la france peut
poser ou de peser au sein des
institutions européennes et
internationales et quel doit être le
rôle de la france dans ce type de
conflit c'est une question sur laquelle
les fons et doit réfléchir dernière
question évidemment dans quelles
conditions et bayal macron va-t-il
pouvoir donc se déclarer candidat
alors emmanuel macron n'est plus le
maître des horloges 18 ce cas qu'est ce
que le prix andré pic souhaitait c'était
réglé cette crise pour faire pour se
déclarer candidat après un succès
européen international puis finalement
il lui reste moins de quinze jours avant
la limite du dépôt des le parrainage et
donc d'une annonce officielle de
candidature et la crise vraisembablement
ne sera pas gérée dans les quinze jours
donc là il est plutôt bloqué en termes
de calendrier il a plusieurs choix soyez
fait le choix de déclarer sa candidature
s'il arrive à avoir un petit à petit
pause dans cette crise diplomatique et
les faire plutôt de manière rapide et de
passer directement à autre chose soit il
peut ne pas là mais c est ce sera
laurent fabius présente conséquence
ionel qui fera la liste le 8 mars des
candidats ayant reçu les 500 parrainages
et ayant affirmé vouloir se représenter
merci beaucoup et aymeric qui a glissé
d'avoir répondu ce matin à nos questions
en direct sur rt france